All right listen up.
What you’re about to see
is some real rock 'em
sock 'em football.
Tee it up!
[whistles]
[grunts]
The line at the candy
store sure was
backed up due to
Mother’s Day tomorrow.
I can’t believe I almost
forgot Mother’s Day.
Umm.
Ahhh!
You said breakfast in
bed wasn’t messy!
Good grief.
Dear Mom, thank you
for my school lunches.
Especially the
bologna sandwiches.
Not so much the Tuna fish.
We got my mom an ice cream
cake for Mother’s Day.
Ahh!
Apparently Mother’s Day is
not her favorite holiday.
I don’t know why I get so upset.
Because you miss your mom?
I never had a mom.
Maybe you miss what moms do!
My dad does all that
mom stuff for me.
For Mother’s Day I’m going
to celebrate my dad.
Woo-hoo!
There are all types
of moms, right?
Of course!
Some kids have two moms!
And even kids like me
can have someone who
acts like a mom.
All those moms deserve
to be celebrated!
[laughs]
♪♪